in different regions of the Far East, and everything was
said for us, however, the
epidemic was replaced by other challenges, also of a
global nature, which threaten the
whole world, I mean the sanction
fever of the West, its undisguised
aggressive attempts to impose
behavior patterns on other countries to deprive them of their
sovereignty and subjugate to their will,
in fact, nothing  this is not usual in this,
this is a policy that has been pursued by the
collective Western for
decades, despite this, Western
countries strive to maintain the former
world order that is beneficial only to them,
to force everyone to live according to the notorious
rules that you yourself think you have
invented yourself and regularly violate
constantly these rules change for themselves
depending on  from the emerging current
cultures, the level of
industrial development of Europe so achieved, the quality of
life of people, socio-economic
stability, all this is thrown into the furnace of the
sanctions furnace, they
are spent at the behest of Washington in the
name of the notorious
Euro-Atlantic unity  but in fact, it
is sacrificed for the sake of preserving the
dictatorship of the United States in world
affairs with a boomerang, everything will return back
just like you asked about
limiting the prices of our say
energy resources here and there makes
some decisions about salt stupid decisions
if she tries someone  to
implement it will not lead to anything good for those
who make this decision, it will not
lead to all the
contractual obligations of the supply contract, and
that some decisions of a
political nature that contradict the
contract will be made, but we simply will not comply with them
and will not supply at all
if  this is contrary to our interests in
this case, the economist will not
supply me with oil and coal
, we will not supply fuel oil, we
will fully fulfill our
contractual obligations,
but if someone tries
to impose something on us, I want to note those who give us
something  then imposes in the wrong position
is today to dictate to us
let them change their minds, we
will only have one thing left to say, like in a
well-known Russian fairy tale, to sentence the
wolf tail to freeze, freeze,
but we have so many of them that we
are ready to meet the growing
needs
of everyone who wants to work with us, this is a
very good and profitable cooperation
for our partners and  are very profitable
, including for European countries,
because our pipeline gas is always
several orders of magnitude more
competitive than liquefied
natural gas brought across the ocean.
economy, in fact, it
is the largest economy in the world today
in terms of purchasing power parity, the
Chinese economy is larger than the
American restriction, then gas prices
and there is not much for us to determine this is stupid
stupidity, in turn, they are not a
market
solution that has no prospects, here
[music]
sat down administrative restrictions  in the
field of world trade, they only lead to
disproportions and higher prices, because
what is happening now in European
markets is the result of the
work of
European specialists of the European
Commission nothing is injured, we are building and the
technologies have been
worked out if necessary, please,
we will turn on Nord Stream 2 if you
are interested in this issue  and I can also
talk in more detail, but they told me a
lot about this that we are ready and waiting for the
pipe to be built, which means that the northern one under the
increased flow is now practically
closed, but everyone is talking, that means
Russia uses
another energy ingot about this weapon and nonsense
what kind of weapons we use we supply
as much as our partners need,
how much they put in for the application
so much we are fulfilling, we are ready to
do it tomorrow, only the button is assigned
, but not us, the
sanctions ordered Nord Stream 2 did
it under pressure from the
Americans if they supposedly and why they
even give themselves want  P  to give birth in
triplicate, well, we know the position of the
former on the former administration